por vigésimos esta semana consecutiva
los israelíes se manifestaron ante La
Vid contra el proyecto de reforma
judicial del Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu he tenido hoy aquí como he
venido en las últimas 25 semanas para
asegurarme de que Israel seguirá siendo
una democracia es un proyecto de ley que
refuerza la que muchos dicen que corroe
la independencia del poder judicial tras
paralizar la legislación en marzo a
causa de las protestas generalizadas y
las acciones sindicales metanyahu
declaró esta semana al Wall Street
journal que seguiría adelante con una
versión modificada del proyecto de ley
la idea de una cláusula de anulación
donde el parlamento magnesio puede
anular las decisiones del tribunal
supremo con una mayoría simple lo
descarte cuando se le preguntó cómo
nombraría los jueces dejó Claro que la
reforma seguía en pie
Está muy claro que la forma de elegir a
los jueces no va a hacer la estructura
actual pero no va a ser
a pesar de algunos movimientos su
mayoría depende del apoyo de la derecha
más dura del país y de los partidos
Ultra ortodoxos y los manifestantes se
muestran escépticos sobre la voluntad de
compromiso del Primer Ministro
una vez que el gobierno vio que la
protesta estaba teniendo impacto dieron
Un paso atrás y ahora están intentando
una técnica diferente hacerlo poco a
poco ahora mismo están intentando anular
el criterio de razonabilidad que es
antidemocrático no cabe duda de que el
proyecto de ley ha dañado la reputación
democrática de Israel en la escena
mundial e incluso ha suscitado la
condena de su Aliado incondicional
Estados Unidos con el presidente biden
entre los que han pedido que se elimine